[Música]
me miran con falso entendimiento No
terminaste el día estás por quedarte
desnuda y salgo me tiro fuera de la
puerta automática y sus cuchillas corro
corro como una enferma de los
trofeos corro sobre la hormigón y
viviendo como un atleta con piernas
nuevas corro para dejar chorrear el mal
en mí Ariana Harwich Muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
France 24 estás acá en la feria del
libro de Guadalajara para presentar la
reedición de la débil mental tu segunda
obra nos podrías contar la historia de
dónde viene Este título y esta historia
Bueno sí Qué lindo escucharte hablar en
español
con acento francés como mis personajes
la débil mental existe desde 2014 pero
bueno como ya saben cada país va
publicando el libro diferentes tiempos
entonces hay una temporalidad
interesante las obras para mí no sé los
otros escritores que piensan yo la
escribí en 2014 pero para México es
nueva o sea para o para otras lenguas no
en Italia acaba de aparecer entonces la
obra va haciendo cada vez va renovándose
y va renovándose la mi manera de leerla
no la débil mental tiene relación como
todo lo que escribo con una aldea un
amor un lugarcito donde vivo en Francia
donde vivía Donde había una chica que
estaba siempre como rara como fuera de
lo de la convención mirando ahí en unas
canaletas tomándose el tren para París y
yo pregunté una vez Quién era y me
dijeron vano se tinte bill montall y la
de Bill montall que es un poco parecido
a lo que quiere decir en francés que en
español Así estaba como la fold pero
también para mí era una mujer enamorada
no después me la crucé en el tren y
parece que iba a ver a su amante en
París entonces ahí surgió la idea de que
una débil mental se pasó no es solamente
una Fall una loca sino una mujer
enamorada
y este libro muestra bien tu estilo el
ritmo de tu escritura una prosa que
puede ser brutal intensa y tus temas de
predilección la familia las madres los
hijos las emociones fuertes y también el
control de esas emociones es un hilo
conductor que sigue es de manera
consciente cuando estás escribiendo o
son temas que siempre vuelven
naturalmente que no puedes controlar la
segunda opción no no lo puedo controlar
Qué es lo mejor que puede pasar No
yo no es que digo Bueno voy a Bueno
listo voy a escribir sobre maternidad
vínculo filiares
familias madres e hijos en realidad la
operación es distinta yo por ejemplo
observo los caballos y las moscas que
están en los ojos de los caballos y de
ahí digo bueno esa sensación me genera
algo relacionado una madre y un hijo o
observó las máquinas agrícolas en las
granjas que le sacan la leche a Los
cabritos
y todas esas observaciones terminan
derivando en la débil mental pero no es
que digo voy a escribir sobre una madre
no funciona así la escritura y bueno la
debil mental hace parte de una trilogía
la trilogía de la pasión que ahora se
puede leer en un mismo libro que se
estrenó en 2022 con mátate amor que
salió en 2012 y precoz en 2015 te parece
importante que exista un sentido en la
lectura de estas tres obras o la gente
puede empezar con la tercera y después
ir navegando sí puede empezar por la
tercera puede empezar por precoz
perfectamente puede empezar por la débil
mental puede leer matate amor última o
no leerla nunca y Simplemente no pasa
nada realmente son independientes son
cuadros de un mismo paisaje que voy
corriendo la cámara como si fuera cine
pero no hay una concatenación de eventos
Lo que sucede es que si lees las tres o
dos se arman un universo más completo
para mí es como si visitaras una aldea
un campo francés y fueras visitando
familia por familia cada libro es una
casa entonces bueno puedes espiar lo que
pasa pero puedes entrar a una casa o a
tres
bueno y Ariana vives en Francia desde
2007 Naciste en Argentina pero hace más
de 15 años que vives en Francia cuál es
tu tu relación con este país Cuál es la
influencia de este país en tu en tu
proceso de de creación total y absoluta
es lo que veníamos hablando antes en
francés y bueno por ahora es una
frustración pero sé que va a haber
revancha porque es una frustración muy
grande hablar de estos libros en
Inglaterra en Alemania en Italia o en
México o en Hungría o en rumania o en
Turquía y resulta que en Francia que es
verdaderamente el lugar que inspira y la
lengua que inspira todos mis escritos es
donde quizás todavía menos
intervengo en el debate literario quizás
porque justamente ahí soy un inmigrante
bueno acá en México no soy un inmigrante
soy una escritora invitada voy a Londres
lo mismo voy a Hungría Pero bueno en
Francia mi condición es la de inmigrante
mi acento me delata ni bien digo Hola
entonces digo bonjo y me dicen de dónde
sos es insoportable pero a la vez bueno
es así pero no sé la relación con
Francia es muy turbulenta muy extraña y
es lo que más me interesaría del mundo
porque mis personajes además en la nueva
novela ni hablar están llenos de
referencias políticas a Francia no a
Pakistán o sea está lleno de referencias
políticas y hablas del impacto del
idioma francés tuvo a veces sientes
inspiración a escribir en francés o
siempre te viene en español
o mezclas a veces los dos cuando uno
vive desde hace mucho tiempo en un país
también en su cabeza Todo está un
poquito mezclado cómo te sientes con el
francés en este proceso al momento de
escribir Sí por ejemplo Ahora cuando te
hablo a vos me frustra no poder
determinados palabras no todas Pero
decirlas en francés porque sería más
exacto yo no quería decir lograr
era como quería decir eso Y me me
frustra mucho si tuvieran tres idiomas o
cuatro querría usarlos todos estoy
segura No
escribí degenerado que es una cuarta
novela que está en anagrama la escribí
en francés y en español a la vez un
ejercicio que hicieron Ya muchos otros
autores
era una novela profundamente bilingüe y
luego la pasé todo al español pero queda
conserva como cuando cuelas unas pastas
conserva el sedimento del francés O sea
que básicamente Yo diría que mis novelas
mis escritos son escritos en lengua
Argentina en español pero están montados
sobre el francés muchas veces invierto
la frase nosotros en español decimos a
dónde vas
o vas a la cocina a la cocina O sea
invierto la lógica de la pregunta y
pongo el verbo al final Como hacen los
francés
dónde va o sea y trato de invertir la
lógica sintáctica y todas tienen esa
extrañamiento y hablando del del sonido
de la música de de un idioma tú explicas
que tus novelas son muy teatrales y
literalmente lo son porque ya ya Existen
un montón de adaptaciones en obras de
teatro de tu de tus novelas es algo que
imaginabas tantas de escribirlas o
durante la fase de escritura está
transformación de las palabras en
imágenes en sonidos en paisajes
sí O sea no me imaginaba concretamente
que iban a hacer obras de teatro que lo
son
ahora pronto en España y también
Argentina en Ecuador en Israel Bueno
también Ojalá en Francia no me lo
imaginaba pero ahora que lo pienso era
muy lógico que el destino fuera ese
Porque yo vengo del teatro del cine
y cuando escribo las novelas soy muy
teatral entonces hay como un escenario
montado cuando las escribo entonces
luego Es lógico que se conviertan en
obras de teatro no y hablando de
adaptaciones ahora una próxima
adaptación en las pantallas grandes se
está preparando la adaptación de matate
amor que fue erigida por Martin corsés
para hacer una película
protagonizada por Jennifer Lawrence y
dirigida por lindsey felicitaciones como
recibiste esta noticia Y cómo ahora
estás Todo se está preparando no sé si
ya sabes si vas a poder ayudar a la
producción acompañar todo este proceso
Bueno sí sabía que Martín scorsese había
elegido
la el libro en realidad los tres pero
bueno en principio matate amor lo sabía
pero la incertidumbre era Bueno cuando
lo iban a anunciar que se haga realidad
Porque
muchas veces compran libros y luego no
las hacen Es lógico pero luego cuando lo
anunciaron en New York Times Jennifer
Lawrence lo anunció y luego salió en
replicado entonces supimos que era
cierto la directora Lyn ramsey que ha
hecho tantas películas alucinantes no
como También tenemos que hablar de Kevin
entre otras no y con bueno con tilda
swington y con y que me encanta que sea
escocesa me parece que es un país
interesante para pensar el Imperio bueno
y van a empezar a adaptar el guión en
diciembre y ojalá pueda participar
Supongo que sí y volviendo a la
literatura Cuáles son tus próximos
proyectos y nos quieres hablar de no sé
una obra sobre la cual estás trabajando
ahora sí En realidad terminé que nunca
se sabe si terminaste Pero bueno de
algún modo Aparentemente terminé una
nueva novela como todas mis novelas son
breves
tienen mucho trabajo de escritura pero
son breves es en toda en diálogo no toda
pero mucho en diálogo que no lo hice
nunca antes y eso me da mucha alegría
haber podido hacer una novela con
diálogo toda hecha de diálogo ahí está
el teatro también y el cine y bueno
saldrá creo principios del 2024 bueno
Muchas gracias de nada y muchas gracias
a ustedes por la confianza sigan con
nosotros hay más noticias
[Música]